Et voilà, un bon kg d'épinards.
C'est pas pour faire de la cuisine,
c'est pour réaliser une photographie à la
chlorophylle pour fixer ce moment historique.
Non, le confinement ne monte pas à la tête.
C’est pour obtenir un anthotype. Allez ! Suivez-moi, je vais vous montrer la recette.
D’abord, vous écrasez des feuilles
d’épinards mélangées avec de l’eau
pour en extraire le jus.
Un jus bien vert
qui contient de la chlorophylle, mais pas que… Puis, vous enduisez
une feuille de papier à dessin
avec ce jus. Quand c'est bien sec,
vous humidifiez.
Puis, vous déposez la silhouette
que vous souhaitez reproduire :
une monture de lunettes par exemple,
que vous recouvrez avec une feuille de plexiglass.
Vous mettez le tout au soleil.
Thermostat… on s’en fiche. L’important c’est la lumière.
Vous laissez reposer 15 minutes à deux heures.
Tout dépend de l’ensoleillement.
Puis, vous retirez la plaque de plexiglass et le masque
et vous obtenez un anthotype.
Que s’est-il passé ?
Ça ne se voit pas, mais le jus d’épinard
contient plusieurs types de pigments.
La chlorophylle masque tous les autres.
Exposée à la lumière cette chlorophylle se dégrade.
On voit alors apparaître une couleur brune/orangée.
C’est un mélange qui contient des pigments,
qu’on ne voyait pas jusqu’à présent.
De la carotène notamment.
À l’emplacement de la monture de lunettes, la couleur est restée vert foncé,
la couleur est restée vert foncé tout
simplement parce que cette zone
est restée à l'abri de la lumière, la
chlorophylle ne s'est pas dégradée.
Tiens au fait, dans "anthotype", on
retrouve la racine grecque
"anto" ce qui signifie "fleur". Si vous
voulez conserver votre anthotype,
mettez-le à l’abri de la lumière.
Car comme les fleurs, c’est périssable.
À demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés,
mais on reste en lien.
pouce bleu, vous pouvez également voir
ou revoir toutes celles des jours précédents
en cliquant sur le côté gauche,
j'en publie une chaque jour
et pur être sûr de n'en louper aucune, eh bien...
abonnez-vous et activer la petite cloche !